this morning congressional Democrats
launched a series of hearings and
investigations into president Trump's
possible conflicts of interests they
come after the president claimed in his
State of the Union address that quote
ridiculous partisan investigations of
his administration could hurt the
economy House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
replied that he should not quote bring
threats to the floor of the house Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
Democrats plans Nancy good morning
good morning and the Democrats are
essentially ignoring the president's
warnings and today alone they are
holding two potentially explosive
hearings one of them into the
president's tax returns Democrats trying
to force the release of those returns
as part of an inquiry into possible
conflicts of interest the other hearing
is going to look at the legality of the
administration's controversial family
separation policy at the border and then
tomorrow they're hauling the acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker before
Congress Democrats even have a subpoena
ready if he tries to claim executive
privilege in response to some of their
questions and on top of all of that the
House Intelligence chair Adam Schiff
announced yesterday that his committee
is going beyond its Russia probe to
examine whether any of the president's
decisions in office have been influenced
by financial considerations the
president responded by calling Schiff a
political hack who is only trying to
make a name for himself and he has
already tweeted this morning that all of
this John amounts to presidential
harassment no okay Nancy I want us
before letting you go I want to switch
gears a little here presidential hopeful
senator Elizabeth Warren is apologizing
again for claims of Native American
aunts ancestry earlier in her career she
spoke to reporters outside her office
let's listen this is from the heart this
is about my family my brothers and it is
about an apology from the heart an
apology for not being more sensitive to
tribal citizenship and tribal
sovereignty and so Nancy what can you
tell us about the timing why is she
doing this now well it was a pretty
sweeping maiya kulfa and has to do with
the fact that she's trying to eliminate
this as a presidential
campaign issue particularly after this
Texas state bar registration card from
the 1980s surface in which she described
her race as American Indian a story
first reported by The Washington Post
she told us that she and her brothers
grew up believing that they were part
Native American but that family lore is
not the same as tribal affiliation and
that she should have been more mindful
of that in this instance and in others
obviously though this is not what she
was hoping to have to talk about just
three days before she's set to announce
her presidential bid John all right
Nancy thank you